as I said earlier Liz Lemon we have a
great show tonight and that is your
allotted time mr. O'Brien now mr.
Richter will be allowed a rebuttal mr.
Richter how do you respond to mr.
O'Brien's assertion that tonight's show
will be great
thank you Dan and good evening America
my opponent has a long history of
exaggerating the quality of his show
case in point
On June 13 2012 he said tonight we have
a really great show but listen to listen
to who was on that show the Verizon guy
the author of a book on honeybees and an
all clarinet band called reading rain
blow that's reading with two E's does
that sound really great to you America I
say no it was a real stinker mr. O'Brian
how do you respond well mr. rickter
talks a big game but how would he know
if the show is great when he spends most
shows napping at his podium wrong or
playing candy crush no one plays candy
crush anymore its face whap now all
right is that the kind of person who has
the temperament to decide if his show
was great or not my opponent has a long
history of Lies one time after a
two-week break you said it's great to be
back
when minutes before the show started you
said I'd rather die than go out there
I say that every night at one time one
time when you were interviewing the guy
from The Mentalist about his book of
panini recipes you said and I quote this
panini recipe sounds fascinating
otherwise no one was fascinated
especially you I mean how you can find
out more about this lie by going to Andy
Richter calm slash panini truth I said
his panini for fascinating and I meant
it don't believe me just check out team
koco.com slash screw you Richter slash
Britney pics underscore a fascinating
got young okay gentlemen time is up mr.
Richter you have thirty seconds for your
closing comments
Thank You America this show is getting
screwed all the good guests are going to
China and Mexico people watch this show
and they're laughing at that's the point
of the show I want to make this show
great again how about that
[Applause]
mr. mr. O'Brien 30 seconds closing
comments andis leading with fear and
negativity when I was elected host of
this show I made a commitment to being a
uniter
I want to bridge the gap between
audience members who are here because
they couldn't get into Ellen an audience
members who are here for the free air
conditioning I believe together we can
make tonight's show truly great but I
can't do it alone
I need your help Andy and your help
audience
[Applause]
of the co-hosts for the Emmy
award-winning series the talk Sharon
Osbourne
[Applause]
I'm gonna head for the star the coke
pasta evil dead and Evil Dead 2 in the
Starz series ash vs. Evil Dead proves
Campbell
very funny comedian Mike Racine
[Applause]
I can see to my opponent I mean I don't
know the third guy but it does sound
like a great show it is a great show and
we have more coming up we'll be right
back Jimmy take
you